you know i used to have really bad
ulcers in college i just wish i would
have known back then what i know
now because there is a very simple
remedy but ultimately you have to
correct your diet because if you had
your diet being corrected you would
never get the ulcer in the first place
so what is an ulcer well it's not a
minor thing it's a major thing it's a
hole in your stomach or your small
intestine where the lining has broken
down
now there are many theories about what
causes an ulcer
from stress
nutritional deficiencies
to
a microbe called h pylori helicobacter
pylori and of course the side effects
from taking nsaids which are medications
but today i'm going to show you a remedy
that can
really help you get rid of an ulcer in
college i had it so bad i would be
waking up in the middle of the night
with this
gnawing
dull
burning pain in my stomach that would
only be relieved if i ate something and
of course the way i dealt with it was
mega
mega amounts of tums which is calcium
carbonate like limestone so i do know
what it feels like to have this
condition and it's
not very pleasant now the most popular
remedy for ulcers would be prolosac
which is a ppi a protein pump inhibitor
type
medication in which it stops the acid
production and i'm not saying it doesn't
work it does work it does help people no
doubt
but there's some slight minor
complications
these are called side effects
like gas
vomiting
nauseousness
headache abdominal pain increased risk
of dementia
increased risk of the infection c diff
increased risk of pneumonia bone
fractures from osteoporosis and polyps
in kidney inflammation but other than
that it's totally safe so the question
is are there safer alternatives than
these medications now one study was an
animal study
the medication called omeprazole
to
cabbage juice and the study demonstrated
that the group that
took the cabbage juice for ulcers showed
an 83 improvement versus an 81 percent
group with the medication group so it
was only slightly better but without the
side effects in another study involving
the comparison of the medication
cymetidine to cabbage showed that the
group that consumed cabbage
healed their ulcers in 15 days
compared to 28 days in the group that
took the medication so let's talk a
little bit about cabbage what is in this
cabbage that helps ulcers well they
isolated it down to
this
vitamin u
now vitamin u is not really a vitamin
it's a term used to describe a group
of sulfur compounds okay these are
plant-based compounds with an s because
there's quite a few of them
and they're made from sulfur so this
group of compounds
are called
glucosinolates now what's very
interesting about glucosinolates
is that it has a very potent effect
to
dismantle and destroy
h pylori one of the most commonly found
microorganisms involved with ulcers so
this is probably why cabbage works so
well
with ulcers now the real question is why
do you have h pylori well i did a video
on this in in a normal person
h pylori is not acting in a pathogenic
form and apparently when your acids go
too low and you don't have enough
stomach acid so the ph
is going higher more alkaline when the
stomach should be between one and three
very very acidic this microbe tends to
overgrow and becomes pathogenic and
starts to create ulcers
and so here the person is left with the
treatment
of
getting rid of the acid that's the very
thing that triggered this infection in
the first place and so originally and
this is my own point of view
ulcers were created by a lack of acid
not
an excess amount of acid and then these
h pylori microbes start growing and then
you get the ulcer so cabbage apparently
will put these things
either in remission or kill them now
there's a couple things you need to know
about cabbage if you cook it too much
you'll destroy this chemical compound so
you can do raw cabbage juice okay that
will work and it doesn't matter if the
cabbage is green or red it'll work the
same you can use steamed cabbage because
apparently you can retain 97
of this compound if you steam it just
don't overcook it so steaming is one way
to consume cabbage
or you can ferment cabbage as sauerkraut
now one tiny problem with fermenting
cabbage is it does reduce this compound
but you then get all these additional
beneficial
uh friendly bacteria when you consume
sauerkraut you get the prebiotics which
is the fiber that feeds your microbes so
there's really four ways i would
recommend consuming cabbage just eating
it raw in some salad or some dish
fermenting it as sauerkraut
steaming it or juicing it which you'd
probably get the most concentrated form
of this phytonutrient
the next video i think you should watch
would be on sauerkraut there's so many
benefits of sauerkraut i think this
would be a really important video check
it out
you